it would take decades for the red planet
to warm up even after it gained the
extra CO2
so in theory this could delay humans
from ever landing on Mars
not only that but this assumes that
dropping thermonuclear bombs on the
planet would go perfectly
keep in mind these are nukes
you know things that can destroy entire
cities
in fact the bombs we'd use on Mars would
be one thousand times stronger than the
ones used in World War II
if a bomb exploded on the planet's
surface instead of up in the atmosphere
some severe damage would occur Not only
would it completely destroy parts of the
planet's surface it would also cause
even more radiation another thing that
would delay us from ever settling on
Mars
it's also very likely that instead of
warming Mars a bomb could cause a
nuclear winter
this could happen from the dust and
particles in the atmosphere caused by
nuclear explosions